est-ce que vous collectionnez cause et
800 ruch lors des collections boîte à
musique une collection de changer une
collection de cannes de chasse de chat à
deux chars d'accord d'avant-vente
sortent bien sûr que moi je connais la
comédienne christine boisson elle
collectionne des couteaux elle en a 75
dans son sort
comment vient d'accuser jamais lannion
balance des chocottes
est ce que est ce que vous avez
babington ce soir est très bien vous
allez l'exploser ce soir lorsque vous
êtes dans un état il va en prendre plein
la gueule
je ne vous ai jamais vu comme ça au
départ départ c'est une simple question
somme toute bête est ce que vous
collectionnez des choses zaoui des
charades alors quoi d'autre les chats
pardon s'est désolé trés bien phénomène
d'aspiration par le bas vous ne voyez
pas mais sous il y une pompe qui est en
train de tout récupérer c'est bon